the budget Jeremy Hunt's first budget
and of course the big question is what
are we going to hear about first of all
of course there will be growth what
happens to economic growth the state of
the economy is there going to be a
recession this is what the obr the
office for Budget responsibility they
did just formal forecasts this is what
they were saying last time around look
at 2023 the Year we're in at the moment
1.4 down so both going down everyone
getting less well off that's a recession
what might happen this time around let's
add some bars on with the average of
independent forecasters and look the Red
Bar in 2023 it's still down but less bad
than it was before minus 0.6 that's why
independent forecasters say but look
over there on the far right hand side
weaker growth according to those
forecasters than the obr was expecting
last time around that really matters and
I'll show you why if we plug that into
what happens with borrowing how much the
government is spending and and getting
in taxes the difference between that is
borrowing borrowing's been pretty high
recently very high indeed the
government's concerned about that 140
billion in the next next year what
happens to that if you assume we are
going to have that kind of change in the
growth forecast well here's what might
happen look those red bars go down so
stronger growth in the short run weaker
growth in the in the long run though
I'll show you why that matters in a
second on top of that lower interest
rates so lower debt interest costs for
the government look at the red bars they
go down a little bit more so as a result
of that and again energy costs because
energy costs are lower than expected
that means it doesn't have to spend as
much on the energy price guarantee might
have a bit more money to make it a
little bit more attractive for
households too again those red bars
going down and actually toss it all up
and you're talking about growth
borrowing coming in about 30 maybe 40
billion pounds less than was forecast
last time around that's a really big
deal and potentially means the
chancellor has some money for a
short-term giveaway why do I say short
term look at the right hand side look at
those two bars on the far right hand
side 20 27 28 actually the red bar is
higher so more borrowing in the future
meaning he can't just splurge and expect
a splurge forever necessarily if he
wants to keep these bars going down
which of course he does
but then there's a question about what
does that mean for us what does it mean
for public services here's Public
Service spending how much has increased
or indeed decreased over the last few
years you can see austerity there but
this goes all the way back to the 80s
and over that 40-year period the average
at which it was going up each year about
1.8 a year more recently it did improve
so look at this on on the right hand
side it went up by about 2.8 percent a
year in recent years what's expected in
the future well only about one percent
so not quite austerity necessarily but
really low increases by historical
standards question is whether Chancellor
does anything about that about public
sector pay or indeed about corporation
tax well the many other issues coming up
we'll find out more in the budget